annoncée depuis des mois le plan de paix
américain a été dévoilé ce mardi en
grande pompe avec une absence notable
celle de la palestine l'une des deux
parties concernées donald trump et
benyamin nétanyahou main dans la main
ont présenté un plan qualifié d' accord
du siècle par le président américain
un projet confié au printemps 2017 au
gendre et conseiller du locataire de la
maison blanche
jared kushner un des points les plus
sensibles de ce document déjà
controversé la reconnaissance par les
états unis de la souveraineté d'israël
sur les colonies dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés
le président américain a également
précisé que jérusalem restera la
capitale indivisible d'israël
la partie est de la ville est seulement
suggéré par washington pour devenir la
capitale d'un éventuel état palestinien
en état qui verrait le jour sous
conditions parmi lesquelles un rejet
clair du terrorisme
trump et enthousiaste au moment de
parler de ce nouveau plan de paix ma
vision présence une occasion gagnant
gagnant pour les deux parties une
solution réaliste à deux états qui
résout le risque que représente un état
palestinien pour la sécurité d'israël
aujourd'hui israël fait un grand pas
vers la paix le premier ministre
israélien s'est lui aussi grandement
félicité de cet accord
monsieur le président je pense qu'au
cours des prochaines décennies et
peut-être au cours des prochains siècles
nous nous souviendrons également du 28
janvier 2020 car ce jour là vous êtes
devenu le premier leader mondial à
reconnaître la souveraineté d'israël sur
des zones comme la judée samarie qui
sont vitales pour notre sécurité et qui
sont au coeur de notre patrimoine
côté palestinien les réactions sont aux
antipodes
malgré des désaccords récurrents avec le
fatah le hamas s'est joint la réunion
d'urgence programmée hier par le
président mahmoud abbas ce dernier a
rejeté en bloc cet accord
je veux dire aux deux trump et netanyahu
que jérusalem n'est pas à vendre
que tous nos droits ne sont pas à vendre
ni à négocier et que votre accord de
conspiration ne passera pas la colère
s'est aussi exprimée dans les rues
palestiniennes
à la suite de l'annoncé commune de
donald trump et benyamin nétanyahou les
manifestants ont témoigné de leur
opposition au projet porté par
washington
s'estimant perdant sur toute la ligne un
plan qui en définitive peu de chance de
connaître un meilleur sort que les
précédentes tentatives américaines